he had to be top of the class in syria
just to have a chance to study medicine
but even the strongest can't stomach the
horrors of war
muhammad saud is a doctor and he's a
refugee
and at the height of the second coveted
wave he worked in the intensive care
department
at one of london's busiest hospitals it
was
really overwhelming working here you
know and see a lot of people around you
you know suffering mohammed is part of
an
nhs england scheme that helps
international medical graduates living
here in the uk
register and work as doctors the nhs
says it's an efficient way
to hire doctors fast just have a look at
your names
is from yemen and when the war started
there in 2014
the profession she worked so hard for
drifted away
just like for me like even talking to my
colleagues is this the end of the jury
as a doctor
once you finish you graduate from school
of medicine all your ambitions
you can't achieve anything so this the
end of the journey or our beginning
at the height of the second wave royal
london specialist
covid unit cared for 160 patients
at a time it was europe's biggest
intensive care department
and tasked with organizing the medical
staff was dr
haika bohar from the time you decide you
need
new specialist doctors it takes a
minimum of 10
sometimes 15 years to really
train them these doctors come already
trained
in terms of monetary value that's very
cheap
there are thought to be over a thousand
refugees on this scheme and
every day they help fill a shortage in
nhs
staff across the country doing things
like cancer screenings and
ultrasounds and assisting in clearing a
backlog
caused by the pandemic there's a
shortage of more than one thousand
consultant radiologists
and muhammad was fully trained in syria
he saves the nhs money
by not having to train him and he
benefits the patients here because we
have a shortage of doctors
brings diversity which can only
strengthen
any team particularly in healthcare
hundreds of medical support workers have
already been employed or are in the
pipeline for getting jobs
doctors here say the scheme is as much
humanitarian
as it is medical sadia chowdhury sky
news
at the royal london hospital in london